do you like it still um
it's alright it's got nice bounce to it
hi there everyone I'm Brady from
numberphile and this is going to be a
bit of a video with a difference because
I've come all the way to Southampton to
visit someone I've never met in the
flesh until now he is real
this is Alan Stewart and for those of
you who watch a few of my videos you'll
be familiar with our ones work because
he makes music as you probably guessed
and he's put music on loads of my videos
and what we're going to do now before we
get going is play a bit of a montage of
some of the videos for which Alan has
composed his masterpieces to get any
kind of accuracy on our final answer we
s be as precise as we can be
so that's some examples of Alan's work
now very quickly before we get going I
must say early on Alan has a YouTube
channel Alan key
eighty-six subscribe to Alan key 86
because if you do that you might make
more music for me so but also Alan does
loads of other things he's always
putting all sorts of cool stuff on there
sometimes he just puts raw tracks of the
stuff he makes for numberphile but he
also does all his own work and it's
always full of really interesting stuff
so go and check it out
allen key 86w link underneath and on the
screen and and everywhere and I'm sure
we'll talk about it more later so first
things first we're going to get to know
the man himself and after we've spoken
about that we're going to talk about
some of the music and some of the maths
and science embedded in the music which
would be really interesting
first of all I've been doing a lot of
talking here you want to say something
yes I didn't want to say all right let
me ask you some questions I think the
first thing we should ask is because
we'll probably get asked about it in the
comments is about your eye which is
slightly your two eyes are slightly
different and I know youtubers are
they're not shy about writing about what
they say should we talk about that
what's going on there let's do that and
in my right eye I have a condition
called band Kirito a--they yeah which is
a build-off of mineral so it's just
cloudy and I can't see out of that eye
at all my left eye is going the same way
like so my vision in my left eye is not
perfect either okay there you go
now you know so you probably don't need
to write thousands of comments what's it
called again the band carrot-top ëthey
band kara toffee there we go
so now let's find out a bit about you as
you have a sort of sciency background or
a mathematical background tellers and I
did a degree in physics at the
University of Southampton and I got my
masters there in 2008 and my musical
background is kind of non-existent
I had piano lessons for two years
when I was a teenager but well because
of my eyesight I never learned to read
music like I can't I can't physically
see the music to read it so that kind of
limited what I could do so I stopped
having lessons but I continued to play
and just kind of taught myself so you've
taught yourself you don't read or write
music how do you if you don't read or
write music what do you do do you just
learn what keys what keys sounds like
what and when you press these in this
order it sounds good or yeah I play by
ear so if I hear something as long as
it's not like bark or something I can
usually emulate it like try and copy
what I hear and I've been told that I
have perfect pitch which is like the
ability to hear a note and just say oh
yeah that sir an a so I I guess that
helps okay don't look what's this
oh deep do you know no you're very
quickly going to learn that waiting note
sir Sir do you know um sometimes I have
to think about it I'll play a different
one it won't be that I wasn't was Ichi I
don't know it was one of these ones one
of those eyes even know what when it was
piano I can play it again it was B it
was B I was way off well but I wasn't
able to play it again
you were so what's that semi perfect
pitch maybe I I think yeah perfect is a
stretch let's just say able to hear a
note and play it back again now you're
not a professional musician that's not
how you make your living
what's your job I am a teacher I teach a
level physics at Queen Mary's College
and I've been a teacher for four years
and I love it people are going to ask
how we ended up working together and so
tell us that story as for as long as
texts had weird that working together
and go back as far as you need okay I
think the first thing I did I'm
embarrassed about it I so I don't
talk about it really yeah like criminals
only daddy no it's that sixty single
song oh you made a sixties himhe sauce
and it wasn't very good like it wasn't
very cool now it wasn't really cool so
I've actually unlisted it now
really yeah cuz it wasn't as good as oh
well anyway I'm gonna tell everyone like
I'm gonna I don't know I'm gonna tell
you all I'm going to tell you Alan made
us Alan makes made a little song about
sixty symbols and he sent it to me
just to see if I thought it was alright
and cuz you'd use some of our video 42
hat you asked permission and he was just
saying that he doesn't like it anymore
and he's unlisted the song he's
embarrassed by it but I think I had some
pretty cool bits to it as well I quite
liked I thought it was very like
Vangelis how you say his name Oh
pendulous yeah I thought a sounded like
I thought its bits of a sounded quite
like him I quite like I quite liked bits
of the song
whether were wonderful
look at our
and as a result of that yes not as a
result of the bit side light that's
right I asked you if you compose some
more music
I think the first bit music I did was
for the Rubik's Cube video where you had
all the different people solving Rubik's
cubes and I wrote some eighties backing
music they actually got a pretty easy
case feeding this would pop green hello
youtube hello Brady this is my Rubik's
Cube ative I asked for it to be kind of
retro and 80s didn't iron yeah yeah and
I also did some other bits of music I
think I sent you maybe four or five
different ideas and actually you ended
up using all of them and on different
videos on different videos yeah it
wasn't my intention but you decided to
use one for periodic videos and another
one later on in numberphile well there
you go shows how good they were let's
let's talk a bit about some of these
tracks then hey we talked about the
Rubik's Cube where you sent a whole
bunch and I use them in different videos
yeah none of them were particularly
mathematical or science none of them had
any particular Maps element to them okay
well that's none let's let's skip to
something to do and let's let's not go
chronologically but let's go to one that
I think we should do with soon and this
is the Fibonacci bagpipes and imagine
that place by way of background I should
probably give some background is I had a
tartan made which was based on the
Fibonacci sequence and as a result I
wanted some sort of Scottish music that
was sort of imbued with Fibonacci nests
and I sent an email to Alan did I
mention his YouTube channel Alan Kay 86
like I said he said to me my Center they
divide over to Alan and one of the best
things about working with Alan is he
works so quickly like I'm so lucky that
people help out with the YouTube
channels and sometimes I'll ask someone
for some music or an animation and
because everyone's everyone's busy
Europe you're a busy man
maybe a week or two later I might get a
response and some help but whenever I
ask Alan for a piece of music sometimes
with a half an hour or an hour I get an
email or something he's
composed and played and recorded and the
Fibonacci bagpipes that even that was a
really quick turnaround thank you I just
had nothing better to do yeah nothing
better being a schoolteacher there is
nothing better than helping out
numberphile but anyway so I wanted some
Scottish music imbued with Fibonacci
sequence and now I'll just play you a
little bit of the music as it appeared
in the video so let's play that now
now I don't see a set of bagpipes in
here I'm guessing you don't own a set
house first of all how were you able to
make a bagpipe noise at all well it
should but I feel like I should
acknowledge the fact that it is just
completely synthesized in a very
unprofessional way I mixed together
trumpets and Piccolo's and various
presets on the keyboard until I had
something that sounded squeaky and
slightly annoying so it's just a
composite of other instruments that
sounds wicked annoying
layered on top of each other yeah yeah
can you can we load that on can we have
a commune have a listen to what they
sound like here it is so if you hit
different keys like
and that okay so that's how we got our
bagpipes I tell you what I'm gonna grab
the other camera and you can talk me
through the Fibonacci nests of it all
okay Alan you've made bagpipe noise talk
to me about the Fibonacci nests of this
piece of music okay the original piece
is in b-flat because that's what I
thought bagpipes 14 - that's the scale
of b-flat but I think to make it simpler
to explain I'll actually play it in C so
you can number the notes here's the
first note number 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and then
of course the 8th note is the octave
what I did was I took the terms in the
Fibonacci sequence and I mapped them
onto the musical scale so if it would
actually seek sequence starts 1 1 2 3 5
so that just comes out as 1 1 2 3 5 the
next term is 8 so I could jump up to the
8th notes but instead I decided to take
it full circle and just go back to the
first note I mean it's the same note
it's still a C so that's the eighth note
so it goes 1 1 2 3 5 8 the next term if
it been actually sequence is 13 so I
suppose I could have continued to climb
up the keyboard the 13th note is that
the next term is 21 the 21st note is
that but that will not sound nice
it doesn't sound right so what I did can
I use maths Thanks what I did was I took
all the terms of the Fibonacci sequence
and I did mod mod seven of the term
which basically means if you take the
number there's the Fibonacci number and
divide it by seven
what remainder are you left with so if
you take say the number eight and divide
that by seven obviously you're going to
get one left over if you take thirteen
and divide that by seven you're going to
have a remainder of 6 so in this column
here these are the result of doing mod
seven all of the Fibonacci terms and
this then allows you to map the notes
into one sort of Zone on the keyboard
and well it gives you one one two three
five one six zero six six five and so on
then I just took those numbers and maps
them onto the C major scale what do you
get you get this
which I've clearly just played an awful
way because every note have the same
length
so to give it a bit more rhythm because
the Scots like their rhythm I just
arbitrarily made the notes whatever
length I thought sounded best so what
you end up with is
which has a bit more of a lilt to it and
it just sounds I'm incredibly impressed
by this because I couldn't do this I'm
impressed by anything I can't do cool
can I just point something out about the
Fibonacci sequence a is that there I
just played 16 notes so you may say okay
well what's the 17th note it turns out
that the 17th note is note number 1 the
18th note is note number 1 the next note
is note number 2 and then 3 and then 5
and it turns out that it's actually
exactly the same sequence again the same
16 notes just keep on cycling I I know I
probably don't need to show you this but
on the spreadsheet you can just keep on
going up to the Fibonacci sequence and
yeah the remainder the the mod 7 number
just keeps cycling I don't know if I'm
explaining that well but so there is no
more to the Fibonacci music I couldn't
possibly have done any more mapping
because it just keeps repeating that's
where that's awesome maybe I'm sure
there's a perfectly logical I'm sure
there is and being a physicist I'm not
quite good enough at the maps to be able
to explain why that is maybe a number
file will be able to explain why this is
excellent
anyway that's that's one Fibonacci
element the other thing is the tempo is
89 beats per minute there's a there's a
pulse click to the music that just taps
a regular 89 beats in a minute now
the drumming in the song isn't just a
simple pulse at 89 beats per minute but
where is that pulse I can't hear a pulse
I had a click track in audacity that was
just constantly ticking at 89 beats per
minute and then you took that out I took
that out just
in time so what is in time with that
then what what's happening 89 times in a
minute
Wow can you play the track for me quite
a quick track yeah sure
there you go that's what 89 beats per
minute sounds like and I just made sure
that I kept in time with that as I was
playing so I was going
Oh
ah of course I took the click track out
after I finished recording because no
one wants to hear a click track and but
Allen that's worried I don't really know
what cuz some notes you do a short
yes I'm along they don't all hit what
what is the thing that's keeping in time
with that Creek truck every flock does
every fourth note have to hit the boo
Paulo and I don't know what you mean by
keeping in time with it oh dear I know
that such inside such a difficult
question um okay I talked about what
you're thinking and what you're doing ah
you ask a lot Bracy
this is how long's videos get married
right right okay so I suppose um I could
play it so that every note lands on one
of the clicks so I could play
except the click tracks just stopped
because it ran it was only 32 bars I
start again and I'll just leave pit ok
it's on leap but you don't do that
because that sounds boring is that right
yeah and then what do you do instead
because if you just if you're going to
break the rules and not follow the click
what's the point of the click track um
well maybe if I talk about breaking the
rules when I break the rules I'm taking
the time interval between one click and
the next click and I'm cutting it in
half for example so when one click
happens I might play two notes of the
same length so I'll just try and
demonstrate that note that was notes on
the click that we try and demonstrate
this is quite difficult yeah that's what
it would sound like to have half the
half the click separation as a note and
I think that's how the music and all
rhythm is is made up you take the click
track and then the spacing between the
clicks you cut it
perhaps in half or you cut it into free
pieces or cut it into four pieces
and usually you stick two notes of those
durations so you know half a clip we
have third of a click and if you put two
notes between clicks yeah are you
playing it 178 beats per minute and I
suppose you could say that I was
except that not every note is two notes
between the clicks some of the notes are
just the duration between one click and
the next do you have a skivvy
oh yeah
sometimes yeah every everything I do in
this song is some multiple of that or
some division of that and I guess that's
what rhythm is all right let's turn that
off there that quick okay so now we know
that eighty nine a Fibonacci number
plays a big role what else you go in
there and drums and I will just need to
change the drum kit on the keyboard
which I know to be number six no 86 I
think no that's the Cuban percussion kit
it sounds nice doesn't it I particularly
like this one this is the orchestral
percussion kit on the keyboard and it's
got some nice low drums and timpani
possibly or I'm not sure it's also got
some snare drums and it's got a snare
roll so you can generate a sort of drum
track I suppose for the song so in the
Fibonacci bagpipes and I use the drums
too to mark out first of all one accent
one loud note one and then the next term
in the Fibonacci sequence is one as well
so another one of those and then two and
then three and then five and those can
be heard underneath the bagpipes about
halfway through the track
that's my favorite bit by the way when
everything comes in I like what I like
how they're going at Fibonacci numbers
maybe that's because the only bit I
recognize yeah yeah yeah it I think it I
think it's punctuated it stands out and
of course there's also the snare
drumming I could have done some clever
Fibonacci's with the snares but instead
I wanted it to remain musical sounding
because I think if I'd based all of the
drum rhythms on the Fibonacci sequence
it would stop sounding musical so for
the snare drums I just did some typical
say okay so there's no Fibonacci there
no
there's one more thing one more element
in the chorus if you will we hear this
melody very short that is the same
melody as Philip Moriarty and Dave Brown
used in the fie song now
what does fie have to do with the
Fibonacci numbers Brady may ask what is
fire to do with the Fibonacci numbers if
you take two consecutive Fibonacci
numbers and you do the bigger one
divided by the little one then the
result is close to the golden ratio
close to Phi now obviously if you choose
little Fibonacci numbers like eight and
five that that comes out to be panic
eight fifths
what's that 1.4 which is not very close
but if you use larger Fibonacci numbers
it tends towards the golden ratio it
gets closer and closer and closer to the
confirmation the proportion is divine
verily the proportion is divine you have
this like mathematical science a
background and not even a background
your physics teacher you have this
interest in music to what extent is
music this arty experience for you and
to what extent are you thinking very
much about numbers and octaves and
science and dividing beats into factors
and things and I think that's a really
good question and I would say none at
all like I don't think in terms of
mathematics I don't think in terms of
the science of it I just literally play
what I think sounds good
however if I want to compose a piece
which is based on say the Fibonacci
sequence or PI then I can use maps to
map it on to music and art and and so I
feel I feel like there is a crossover
but I'm not conscious of it when I'm
playing so when I drop you an email and
say can you help me can you come up with
some music based on this mathematical
principle how much is that putting a
straitjacket on you and how much is that
making it more fun and enjoyable I I
think sometimes having a straitjacket
having a very specific brief can
actually really help because if you're
just told to compose some background
music for I don't know an elephant or
actually no that's probably quite easy
to do actually but but if you're if
you're just asked to compose a nice
piece of music where do you start
whereas if you're asked to compose a
piece of music that's based on Fibonacci
then that does actually help to have the
restriction or speaking of restrictions
another request that I put into it was
to help with some music for our video
about calculating pie with pies which
was an interesting video and certainly
attracted some interesting comments not
because of your muse
because of our use of pies but let's not
go into that let's talk about the music
because do you remember what I asked you
for I can't even remember what I asked I
told you what we were doing you told you
told me that you were gonna measure pie
using laser pies and you wanted
something quirky you asked for and but
that know what there was some kind of
toing and froing on this one wasn't they
used did you send me something and I yes
know what I think what it was was he I
think you said you were going to do a
video yes you said you were going to do
a video where you were going to measure
by using pies and could I come up with
some music it could be based on pie you
said and I thought it's got to be based
on pie because if it's not based on pie
then what's the point
really so I sent you some just very and
light piano music with a sort of
classical feel it was very background a
very similar to the spaghetti numbers
music well play let's play that now
because I still have it let's play what
Alan first sent
you weren't you weren't unhappy you said
it was nice but then I asked you if
because you described the activity to me
I asked you was there any sort of sense
of it being a bit sneaky like you were
doing something you weren't supposed to
be doing because what I done was I
played around a bit more with PI and I
discovered that on a minor scale as
opposed to a major scale and it had a
very different feel to it and I've come
up with something that I thought was
added quite James Bond II was how I
worded it in my mouth he I believe so
and so we had a tree under that was
something different we did yes something
with a bit more tension to it a lot of
people who I showed the video said it
wasn't what because I had told a lot of
people like my friends and things what I
was doing and that you were making some
music yeah and then when I showed them
the the cut piece yeah a lot of them
said that's completely not what I
expected the music do you like yeah and
it works really well so it was it was
kind of like I think everyone got from
everyone who knew who had an expectation
of what that video was going to be like
mmm was throwing bit of a curve ball but
I still I still really liked it
my goal is to not actually do any
measurements other than using pi so the
entire thing is gonna be PI base we get
the circumference and an exact number of
pies it'll take shall we talk to people
about the music and tell them about how
you've embedded pie yes let me go get
the camera
I come up with very boring names which
are just for my benefit to remind me
what the feel of it is and I think this
one was probably just called oh no wait
no this had an important name this was
called PI March because musically it's
similar to a March like a marching band
and Pi Day is in March very good by the
way if anyone's hearing of the
construction work outside there's
nothing we can do about that it's
because Allen's having another house
built cause he's a millionaire okay
so again it's the I don't know how to
describe it
it's very conventional to map I think
the digits of a number onto a scale and
with Fibonacci we were putting the
numbers of the Fibonacci sequence onto
the notes of the C major scale those
ones okay yeah so just to be different
just to be outrageous I thought let's
put PI on a minor scale so here's the
state why is that outrageous because I'm
using hyperbole office Lea you're
exaggerated it's not wise then why is
that outside the box or why is that a
twist
sure well there have been quite a few
people who have put PI to music um by
heart for one and some other people and
there's a really well-known video called
sounds of Pi I think in all of the
videos I've ever seen
they've always put PI on a major scale
Professor Moriarty put PI on a major
scale on the guitar three one four one
five
nine bend up to nine back to two and
then we've got six by three five eight
nay so I thought I'd like to hear what
it sounds like
on a minor scale just just to see and
and it sounds quite different go I need
to play it okay so first of all the
notes of the minor scale go like this
so very different feel it's it's a sad
scale as my piano teacher would have
said the third note the first nation the
fourth note the first note the fifth
note the ninth the second and in the
sixth and the fifth so just then I
played it pretty much on a pulse just
boring which to me didn't really have
much of a rhythm to it so again I just
arbitrarily made the notes as long as I
wanted them to be until it sounded good
so we ended up with aa there's actually
a rest at the start which I have to play
with the left hand
sorry it goes and that that rhythm
I thought sounded good and that's what I
ended up with what were you doing there
was that breaking the rules or was that
part of pie as well that little thing
you did with your left hand well that's
a little bit of a flourish you put in
for musical room that was that was the
RT musical side of me and has nothing to
do with maths it's just me making it
sound good okay so the notes were based
on PI you went a bit further didn't you
as usual yeah yeah the the tempo the
number of beats per minute was some
multiple of Pi it was 104 beats per
minute
why's that was that that's pi x 33.4
here occurring why did was PI pi times
100 divided by free yoson what else was
marching with drums and things were
there in the PI March yes yes the same
drum beats that were in this had been
actually the same principle so the first
digit of pi is free so there were three
blasts on drum and one blast on the drum
and then four and that I think that
stands out that's quite obvious
this is this is a mild problem because I
want to go from from the very edge of
the circle but as you can see I've
positioned all the pie like for you when
you make a bit of music like you do for
people like me and then you see the
video on YouTube with your music on
what's that like
and I I love it I'm always really
excited if it's going to be a video with
some music in and I guess Denis it makes
makes it come alive is it different for
you when you see the video I said this
is what the video is about and that's do
you feel like no that's not what I
expected the video to be like or how I
expected my music to be used um I think
usually your your editing fits really
well the pie with the music so in the
pie video you cut on the beat for
example or you would cut at the end of a
phrase and so that I was really
delighted with how it looked in the end
it matched music
do you like it still um
it's alright it's got nice bounce to it
and don't allow us to say you don't
listen listening to your own music oh
and I guess I play it I play it I play a
play I practice it I record it I listen
to it and so after you've heard it like
50 times it it stopped it loses its
initial excitement and the feeling that
you get from it and it just becomes like
a song you've heard too much on the
radio but to begin with when I first
came up with that it I just as they
smile him to myself it was it just
sounded so good yeah I like I like
making something up and I enjoy it for
the first hour or so I've made a little
list here of some of the other bits of
music that I particularly enjoyed I just
wanted to ask you a bit about the making
of them our Good Will Hunting video
because we made a video about
mathematics in google hunting I emailed
you and said basically can you make
something that sounds like the theme
music from Good Will Hunting
yeah which obviously because I can't use
the actual music and you came up with
this
which I really liked it really sounds
like the theme of Good Will Hunting
without without being and how the thing
is that tell us about how you came up
with that cuz I'm really curious yeah
and so I've seen Good Will Hunting but I
can't say I remember the music so I went
on YouTube I just searched for the
thinking and I listened to it probably
for about an hour on just in the
background just having it there so I I
felt like I was trying to soak it up and
there were certain parts of it because
it's quite a complicated piece of music
like there's loads going on and it's a
bit it's a bit crazy but there were
parts of it that I thought I can emulate
what Danny Elfman the composer has done
here so there's the sort of high-pitched
piccolo like sound at the beginning and
then there's also something quite
beautiful about it but also something
slightly discordant like in the
introduction those piano chords are not
what I would think of as normal chords
they're a bit dissonant a bit odd so
taking all those different bits that I
soaked up from it I just tried to write
something that sounded similar
when you listen to something for an hour
though how do you like you don't want a
song gets stuck in your head yeah how do
you stop that being so stuck in your
head that you can be original with it
I think the Good Will Hunting theme tune
is quite unique in the even after
listening to it for an hour I still find
it quite unpredictable like because it
is such an interesting rich piece of
music there's so much going on in it
that for that I didn't actually that's
why I had to listen to it for so long
because normally if I hear a song four
or five times I can usually just play it
after that but yeah that seam chain is
complicated so I didn't get tired of it
is your is your mimic is your homage to
it equally unpredictable no no my homage
to it is simple by comparison and it I
feel like mine is a little bit more
tuned for like there's an actual tune
that you could sing along too whereas in
Danny Elfman's score it's quite a random
piece of music and I I challenge anyone
to sing the theme tune to Good Will
Hunting whereas I think mine you could
actually sing it back alright well if
anyone sings the theme to decanting or
if they sing Ellen his version of it and
post it as a video response I will allow
the videos both because that will be
quite a sight in words yes such an
Olympics
what another piece of music this is
actually more of a project that you did
quite independently of what I was doing
and that's the dragon curve music yeah
the obviously we did a video about the
dragon curve and at you and there was
there are other animations that have
been done and you contacted the animator
and you made your own piece of music to
their animation and then we sort of
brought it all together into a
numberphile video yeah
that's obviously a really nice piece of
music is that mathematical or inspired
or was that just you making a nice piece
of music and I I'd say that the
mathematical link is even weaker than
the PI song Fibonacci song but to me it
does reflect things about the curve
about the shape the way it unfolds yeah
there are parts of it that to me do
connect with the with the shape
it's quite difficult to explain but one
thing actually about the animation is
that it rotates and so in my head I had
the idea of circles and in music there's
this thing called the circle of fifths
and I wanted to use the circle of fifths
somewhere in the song to reflect that
rotation of the animation and there was
something about the animation that just
looked like the original one that looked
quite lonely and it was just a fractal
forming slowly in a vast black space so
I wanted something that sounded lonely
shall I carry on talking deal now you
can stop having one more thing and this
is actually this is not numberphile it
wasn't for a number for our video it was
for a deep-sky video yeah as far as I
know there's no maths or science
involved but it's actually my favorite
piece of music that you've made yummy so
I wanted to ask you about it and and
hear a bit about the story from your end
yeah and that's a piece of music that
you called time passes oh yes yeah I'll
tell it from mine first
basically I was in Paris and I went to
Charles Messier grave and I'm going to
stop now because the battery's about to
run out and we change the battery in the
camera as I was in it I was in Paris and
I went to Charles Messier grave and I
wanted a piece of music to reflect this
walking through the cemetery and I
emailed you and basically I just said
I've just been walking through a
cemetery and I want a piece of music
that shows me walking through a cemetery
and you sent me really quickly while I
was still in the hotel he sent me like a
few options from memory and I really
liked all of them but they were all
really loved I could have used any of
them be in the end I used this one
what happened when I send you this email
to resolve in these pieces of music I
think I find it easier to write sad
sounding music so you said you were in a
cemetery so I thought it's got to sound
sad you also said that the video was
going to feature you traveling to the
place so I wanted something that had a
bit of movement to it a bit of motion
which is why it's got a fairly fast
pulse is like a ticking of a clock and
that's why I call it time passes as well
but yeah well I liked it slow down
thank you for all the all the bits of
music you have made for the numberphile
videos I know from the comments under
the videos that people watching also
enjoy them and a final reminder
allen-key
86 is the youtube channel go and
subscribe
I read the let me tell you the main
reason I want you to subscribe is
because every time I link to Alan's
channel I get an email from him where he
says all five new people have subscribed
and he gets really excited and says he
knows when I put a video up because you
have like 10 new subscribers or 30 new
subscribers and like I'm feeling it
disappointed that so few people
subscribe after all the hard work you
put in so if a whole bunch here you go
and subscribe well that would be good
wouldn't it thank you thank you yeah
why did they subscribe there what do
they they shouldn't just do it to be
nice to me or you what are they going to
get if they do they will get piano music
I try and upload maybe you once a week
or once a fortnight something I've
written some composition occasionally I
do something of it
bit different like a song then alright
yeah and just as a little little teaser
I know because we were talking
off-camera that Alan is working on a
couple of new compositions which
hopefully might appear on numberphile if
I can secure the rights and you'll do
and you're doing them with professor
Phil Moriarty who also appears in
numberphile and sixty symbols so and I
have had a bit of a preview and they're
pretty they're pretty exciting they're
pretty quirky but they've been different
there are different one of them I really
like one of them is I like for its
craziness so they'll be coming so so
stay tuned to numberphile and sixty
symbols but also two allen key 86
because Allen puts a lot of his raw
material and videos of him playing the
pieces appear on that channel so it's
always a good little supplementary to
some of the stuff you see on them for
those long slender piano fingers there
we go which is so famous on your channel
thank you thank you for watching I don't
know how long this video is going to be
we
accorded 54 55 minutes what loads so do
you think we can for 55 minutes on them
before people won't watch that and
identically I'll cut the bits there I'll
cut the bit out what you got really
abusive and start swearing yeah
you